Sally is with us in Minneapolis
hi Sally how are you hi Dave I'm good
how are you better than I deserve what's
up another question for you my husband
and I are and I'm at 20 we've completed
baby steps 133 paying off $82,000 well
we're in stuff 436 thank you
and our goal we want to keep increasing
our income to pass or how it's faster
super so at work this week we just
completed our reviews and raises and I
found proof that I am being paid less
than my male counterparts in the same
position and we both received the same
rating on our performance evaluation we
want my husband I want to start a family
in the next couple of years so I don't
want to leave because I'm eligible for
FMLA but is there anything I can do if I
feel like if I bring it up I might be on
a short list to get let go how do i
navigate this mm-hmm
so the corporate culture is if you if
you accept this level of sexism and
ridiculous treatment that you're going
to be let go if you accept it you can
just don't rock the boat you're okay
but if you if you come in and and and
tactfully not belligerently bring up the
question you feel like that the
corporate culture is very threatening
yeah I saw the information probably I
wasn't supposed to but it's proof that
I'm being paid less for the same role in
the same way I wasn't supposed to mean
you were snooping away and something you
were supposed to be out I was left on
your desk accidentally yeah I was left
out by my manager when you were showing
any mind okay then that's innocent you
weren't being conniving or manipulative
and so well I you know here's the thing
I don't think I could work there if you
can't sit down and ask the question
calmly if you're unable to do that you
need to look for a job you really do
because that's just that this is not
right
forget all the laws and forget a
feminist movement it's a simple thing of
you're doing the same work as someone
else man or woman and got the same
rating and you're doing explanation as
to why you didn't get the same pay
change that's a fair thing okay let's
say it was three ladies in the area and
not not you know it wasn't male/female
right and it was it was and you look
down and you went well I mean I got the
exact same rating as these other two
chicks and I didn't get nothing you know
that's just wrong I would want to know
that and so I think maybe that's the way
to couch the question and and not make
it sound like some kind of raving
feminist thing it's just a basic fair
human fairness thing right and it's
because it's not right I agree with you
and if that was happening inside of our
organization I would have a fit if it
you know now it if there if there are
other factors that go into deciding a
raise other than just this performance
review then that's something to you know
you'd want to learn about I least want
to know the reasoning if it's valid that
were there so who can you talk to in
your leadership team very calmly and say
I accidentally saw this my manager left
it right in front of me when we were
doing this I wasn't snooping in filing
cabinets I'm not trying to stir up
trouble but if the roles were reversed
and someone did this to you regardless
male or female and the people in your
department male or female were making
the same review that I would you were
making and you didn't get the same pay
and didn't get the same raises then you
would want to know why wouldn't you a
normal reasonable human would and if you
can't ask a leader in your organization
that question very calmly and and not
get on a short list to get fired you do
need to get out of there
thanks Dave I really appreciate your
advice yeah
can you yeah I think so I mean it's I
really like my manager and respect him
so I think it's worth having you know an
adult respectful conversation with him
about it thank you I would start with
that I would start with that and go hey
listen this is awkward as crud and I
really don't want to have this
conversation but I would be up at night
and feel like crap if I didn't have it
and I respect you so much
and I like you and I just think I can
talk to you about this without stirring
up trouble because I'm not trying to
stir up trouble I just need I need some
help understanding and maybe couch it
that way if somebody came into my office
and said that versus I demand to be paid
the same
thank you give me a give me again I'll
just fire somebody but that starts that
stuff okay and I'll deal with the
repercussions you know I'm not gonna I
don't do with people demanding stuff
when I own the place but if you come in
respectfully and you go hey I don't
really respect your leadership I really
like you as a person I accidentally saw
this and I need some help I'm struggling
with this and it's not a male and I
really would take the female part of it
off it's not a male-female thing it's
just a the same people in my same area
doing my same work or make it more than
me with the same reviews I don't
understand
did I do something wrong and if you
couch it that way they might be really
really red-faced and embarrassed and go
oh my gosh we got to correct this but
but the threatening thing or the
belligerent thing has got to be way off
the table
you didn't approach me with it that way
so I don't think you will Sally but I I
think you've got a good guy there that
you can at least ask the question and if
you do it that way and you still get on
a short list of some kind to be fired
then you do need to it's okay you took
the right chance you took the right risk
because that's not a place you want to
work if they straight up just because
somebody's female don't pay them that's
just not a place if they straight up
that's their policy that's not written
down but they actually do it on purpose
you don't work
long-term short-term for that matter you
know because I got ladies in this place
that I'll perform the guys and they get
paid more yeah it didn't do with you
know I don't care you know what color
you are I don't care what sex you are
all I care you get crap done you know
and you get paid based on that we don't
pay you based on the other stuff you
don't pay you you know I won guys I got
I got a lot of degrees and I'm like yeah
well you know you're raised here is
effective when you are Bubba so I don't
care about your degrees you know so it's
that kind of stuff and that's how most
good business people think but not
everybody's good sometimes people just
straight up are racist and say our
straight-up sexist and you just don't
want to hang out with those kind of folk
so but don't make it a belligerent
political issue either you're not going
to gain ground doing that I would just
leave all that off the table and just
say if it was a bunch of ladies I'd
still feel it exactly the same way why
am I not getting if I'm not as good did
I do something wrong
teach me lead me and I think the guy's
gonna be embarrassing I bet he corrects
it bet they correct it I bet it scares
the crap out of them and it should this
is the Dave Ramsey show